Il y a 10 ans de cela, j'ai accepté d'enseigner le développement global
à des étudiants suédois. Je venais de passer
20 ans à étudier la faim en Afrique avec des institutions,
donc je connaissais un peu le sujet.
J'ai démarré un cours appelé Santé globale dans notre
université médicale, Karolinska Institute.
j'avais un peu le trac, je dois dire. Après tout, ces étudiants
étaient extrêmement brillants,
les meilleurs du pays... peut-être qu'ils savaient déjà
tout ce que je comptais leur apprendre. J'ai donc fait un petit test avant de commencer.
Et il y a une question qui m'a permis d'apprendre beaucoup de choses :
"Sur ces cinq paires, quel est le pays qui a la mortalité infantile la plus élevée ?"
Dans chaque paire proposée,
l'un des pays avait une mortalité infantile deux fois plus importante que l'autre.
Ça fait une grosse différence.
Je ne vais pas vous demander de faire le test, mais c'est la Turquie,
la Pologne, la Russie, le Pakistan et l'Afrique du Sud.
Et voici les résultats des étudiants suédois. J'ai eu
une intervalle de confidence, et j'étais ravi des résultats.
1,8 bonne réponse sur les cinq possibles. Cela voulait dire
qu'il y avait une place pour un professeur et
(rires) pour mes cours.
Mais un soir, alors que je compilais le rapport,
je me suis rendu compte de quelque chose. J'ai démontré
que les étudiants suédois les plus brillants avaient, statistiquement parlant,
moins de connaissances sur le monde que les chimpanzés.
(Rires).
Parce que les chimpanzés auraient 50 % de bonnes réponses
si je leur donnais deux bananes avec le Sri Lanka et la Turquie.
Mais pas les étudiants. Le problème pour moi, ce n'était pas l'ignorance,
c'était les idées préconçues.
J'ai également réalisé une étude contraire à l'éthique sur les professeurs du Karolinska Institute,
(rires)
cet institut qui décerne le prix Nobel de médecine,
et dans ce cas, les professeurs sont au niveau des chimpanzés.
(Rires).
C'est là que je me suis rendu compte qu'il y avait un besoin de communication
car les informations sur ce qui se passe dans le monde,
sur la santé des enfants dans tous les pays, ces informations existent.
On a créé un logiciel qui fonctionne de la façon suivante : chaque bulle correspond à un pays.
Ce pays là, c'est la Chine. Là, c'est l'Inde.
La taille de la bulle correspond à la population du pays, et cet axe là, c'est le taux de fécondité.
Parce qu'en fait, mes étudiants...
quand ils ont regardé le monde, et que je leur ai demandé :
"Que pensez-vous du monde ?"...
J'ai découvert que c'était un livre de Tintin.
(Rires).
Ils m'ont répondu : "Le monde est toujours divisé entre 'nous' et 'eux'.
Nous, c'est les Occidentaux, eux, le Tiers monde."
"C'est quoi le monde occidental pour vous ?"
"Une vie longue, une famille réduite... dans le Tiers monde, c'est l'inverse."
Voici donc ce que j'ai mis là. J'ai inscrit le taux de fécondité : nombre d'enfants par femme,
un, deux, trois, quatre, jusqu'à huit enfants par femme.
Depuis 1962, on a des informations précises sur la taille des familles dans tous les pays du monde.
La marge d'erreurs est très faible. Là j'ai inscrit l'espérance de vie à la naissance,
de 30 ans pour certains pays à 70 ans pour d'autres.
En 1962, il y avait un ensemble de pays
industrialisés, dont la taille des familles était réduite et l'espérance de vie était importante.
Et il y avait à côté les pays en voie de développement,
avec de grandes familles et une espérance de vie relativement courte.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé depuis 1962 ? On veut voir le changement.
Les étudiants ont-ils raison ? Est-ce qu'il y a toujours deux types de pays ?
Ou est-ce que les données ont changé pour les pays en voie de développement ?
Où est-ce qu'ils sont ? Quelle est leur espérance de vie ?
Voyons voir. Nous avons arrêté le monde. Il s'agit là de statistiques des Nations
Unies... Voilà. Vous voyez ?
C'est la Chine, là, avec une santé qui s'améliore.
Tous les pays d'Amérique du Sud tendent vers des familles de taille plus réduite.
Les jaunes, ce sont les pays arabes,
qui ont des familles plus importantes, mais... non, une vie plus longue, en fait.
Les Africains sont en vert. Ils restent là.
Là, c'est l'Inde. L'Indonésie évolue vite.
(Rires).
Dans les années 1980, le Bangladesh était toujours avec les pays africains.
Mais à présent... c'est un miracle qui s'est produit :
les imams ont commencé à faire l'apologie des plannings familiaux.
Ils arrivent là. Et dans les années 1990, l'épidémie de sida
a réduit l'espérance de vie des pays africains...
Le reste se retrouve là,
avec des familles réduites et une espérance de vie importante... Un nouveau monde.
(Applaudissements).
Je vais faire une comparaison entre les États-Unis d'Amérique et le Vietnam.
En 1964, l'Amérique, c'est des familles réduites et une espérance de vie importante;
au Vietnam, c'est l'inverse. Et voici ce qui se produit :
malgré la guerre et tous ses morts,
l'espérance de vie a augmenté. À la fin de l'année,
les plannings familiaux ont été lancés, et la taille des familles a commencé à diminuer.
Les États-Unis ont une espérance de vie plus longue,
la taille de la famille ne change pas. Dans les années 1980,
ils ont abandonné le communisme et passent à l'économie de marché,
et tout a progressé rapidement. Aujourd'hui,
l'espérance de vie et la taille de la famille sont les mêmes au Vietnam
en 2003 qu'aux États-Unis en 1974, à la fin de la guerre.
Je pense que nous ne nous rendons pas compte
de l'importance des changements survenus en Asie,
des changements sociaux avant les changements économiques.
Passons à présent à autre chose... Voici comment nous pouvons
représenter la distribution des revenus dans le monde.
Un dollar par jour, 10 dollars par jour, 100 dollars par jour.
Il n'y a plus de fossé entre les riches et les pauvres, c'est un mythe.
Il y a une petite bosse là. Mais il y a des gens à tous les niveaux.
Et si on regarde où arrivent les revenus...
là, c'est 100 % des revenus annuels du monde. Et les 20 % les plus riches
en obtiennent environ 74 %. Et les 20 % les plus pauvres,
en obtiennent environ 2 %. Cela montre bien que le concept
de pays en voie de développement est peu convaincant. On parle d'aide...
les gens ici qui aident les gens qui sont là-bas. Mais au milieu,
il y a la majorité de la population mondiale, qui détient 24 % des revenus.
On l'a déjà entendu. Mais quels sont-ils ?
Quels sont les différents pays ? Je peux vous montrer l'Afrique.
Voici l'Afrique. 10 % de la population mondiale, la majorité vivant dans la pauvreté.
Voici l'OCDE. Les pays riches. Le country club de l'ONU.
Et ils sont de ce coté. L'Afrique et l'OCDE se chevauchent.
Et voici l'Amérique du Sud. On y retrouve tout l'éventail de ce qu'il y a sur Terre,
du plus pauvre au plus riche.
Et encore au-dessus, on peut mettre l'Europe de l'Est, l'Asie de l'Est,
et l'Asie du Sud. Qu'obtient-on si l'on retourne en arrière dans le temps,
vers 1970 ? Il y a plusieurs bosses alors.
Et nous avons les Asiatiques qui vivaient dans une pauvreté absolue.
Le problème mondial d'alors était la pauvreté en Asie. Et si on avance dans le temps,
vous verrez que pendant que la population croît, il y a
des centaines de millions d'Asiatiques qui sortent de la pauvreté et d'autres
qui y arrivent, et voici la situation d'aujourd'hui.
Et le meilleur scénario d'après la Banque mondiale est que cela va se produire
et que nous n'aurons pas un monde divisé en deux. Nous aurons la majorité de la population au milieu.
Bien sûr, c'est une échelle logarithmique ici,
mais notre conception de l'économie est une croissance en pourcentage. Nous la voyons
comme une possibilité d'augmentation en pourcentage. Si je change ça et que je prends
le PIB par individu à la place du revenu par foyer, et que je change
les données individuelles en données régionales du produit domestique brut,
et si je mets ces régions là, la taille de la bulle représente toujours la population.
Vous avez l'OCDE ici, l'Afrique subsaharienne là,
et nous déplaçons les États arabes ici,
venant d'Afrique et d'Asie, nous les séparons,
et nous allongeons l'axe. Je peux donner une nouvelle dimension
en ajoutant les valeurs sociales, l'espérance de vie infantile.
Maintenant j'ai l'argent sur cet axe et j'ai les chances de survie de l'enfant là.
Dans certain pays, 99,7 % des enfants survivent au-delà 5 ans.
Dans d'autres, seulement 70 %. Et là, il semble y avoir un fossé énorme
entre l'OCDE, l'Amérique latine, l'Europe de l'Est, l'Asie de l'Est,
les États arabes, l'Asie du Sud et l'Afrique subsaharienne.
La linéarité est très forte entre la survie de l'enfant et l'argent.
Mais laissez-moi diviser l'Afrique subsaharienne. La santé est là et la meilleure santé est ici.
Je peux aller ici et je peux diviser l'Afrique subsaharienne par ses différents pays.
Et quand elle éclate, la taille de la bulle de son pays reste égale à la population.
La Sierra Leone est en bas. L'Île Maurice est en haut. L'Île Maurice a été le premier pays
à s'affranchir des barrières commerciales et à pouvoir vendre son sucre.
Elle pouvait vendre ses textiles selon les mêmes conditions que les Européens et les Nord-Américains.
Il y a de grandes différences en Afrique. Et le Ghana est là, au milieu.
En Sierra Leone, l'aide humanitaire.
Ici en Ouganda, l'aide au développement. Ici, l'investissement, ici,
vous pouvez y aller en vacances. C'est une énorme variation
au sein de l'Afrique dont nous tenons rarement compte - que ça s'égale en tout.
Je peux diviser l'Asie du Sud ici. L'Inde est la grosse bulle du milieu.
Mais il y a une grosse différence entre l'Afghanistan et le Sri Lanka.
Je peux diviser les États arabes. Comment sont-ils ? Même climat, même culture,
même religion. Mais de grosses différences. Même entre voisins.
Yémen, guerre civile. Émirats arabes, de l'argent équitablement réparti et bien utilisé.
Indifféremment du mythe. Et cela inclut les enfants des étrangers qui travaillent dans le pays.
Les données sont meilleures que ce que l'on pense. Beaucoup pensent qu'elles sont mauvaises.
Il y a une marge incertaine, mais on peut voir la différence ici :
Cambodge, Singapour. Les différences sont plus importantes
que la faiblesse des données. Europe de l'Est :
l'économie Soviétique pendant longtemps, mais au bout de dix ans,
c'est très, très différent. Et voici l'Amérique latine.
Aujourd'hui, inutile d'aller à Cuba pour trouver un pays sain en Amérique latine.
Le Chili aura une mortalité infantile inférieure à celle de Cuba d'ici quelques années.
Et ici, voici les pays à haut revenu de l'OCDE.
Nous pouvons obtenir le modèle mondial,
qui est plus ou moins comme ceci. En observant
ce à quoi ressemble le monde en 1960, il commence à évoluer. 1960.
C'est Mao Tsé-toung. Il a fait de la Chine un pays en bonne santé. Puis il est mort.
Ensuite, Deng Xiaoping a amené l'argent en Chine et a ramené le pays sur le devant de la scène.
Nous avons vu comment les pays vont dans des directions différentes comme ceci,
c'est donc compliqué de trouver
un pays qui regroupe tout les schémas mondiaux.
Je voudrais revenir ici, en 1960.
J'aimerais comparer la Corée du Sud qui est là, avec le Brésil,
qui est là. J'ai perdu l'étiquette. Et je voudrais comparer l'Ouganda,
qui est ici. Je peux le faire avancer, comme ceci.
Vous pouvez voir que la Corée du Sud progresse très rapidement
alors que le Brésil est nettement plus lent.
Et si on revient en arrière, ici, et que nous les traçons comme ceci,
vous pouvez voir que la vitesse de développement
est très différente. Les pays évoluent plus ou moins
au même taux en rapport argent et santé, mais il semble possible de progresser
plus vite en étant en bonne santé plutôt qu'en étant riche.
Et pour illustrer cela, prenons l'exemple des Émirats arabes.
Autrefois, c'était un pays minier. Ils ont trouvé du pétrole,
ils ont gagné énormément d'argent, mais la santé ne s'achète pas au supermarché.
Vous devez investir dans la santé. Vous devez scolariser les enfants.
Vous devez former du personnel de santé. Vous devez éduquer la population.
Et le Sheikh Sayed l'a fait d'une manière admirable.
Malgré la chute du prix du pétrole, il a amené son pays jusque là.
Nous avons donc une meilleure approche de l'aspect du monde,
où tout les pays ont tendance à mieux utiliser leur argent
que par le passé. Maintenant, c'est, plus ou moins,
si vous regardez la moyenne des données des pays. Ils se présentent ainsi.
Mais il est hasardeux d'utiliser des moyennes car il y a une grosse
différence entre les pays. Donc si je vais par là, nous pouvons remarquer
que l'Ouganda aujourd'hui est semblable à la Corée du Sud en 1960. Si je divise l'Ouganda,
il existe de grandes différences au sein de l'Ouganda. Voici les quantiles de l'Ouganda.
Les 20 % des Ougandais les plus riches sont là.
Les plus pauvres sont ici en bas. Si je divise l'Afrique du Sud, c'est ainsi.
Si je descends et que je regarde le Niger, où il y a eu une terrible famine
dernièrement, cela ressemble à ça. Les 20 % les plus pauvres du Niger ici,
et les 20 % les plus riches d'Afrique du Sud là.
Nous pouvons ensuite discuter des solutions existant pour l'Afrique.
Tout en ce monde existe en Afrique. Et on ne peut pas
parler d'un accès universel au VIH [traitement] pour ce quantile ici en haut
avec la même stratégie que pour celui-ci en bas. L'amélioration du monde
doit être fortement replacée dans son contexte, et ce n'est en aucun cas pertinent
à un niveau régional. Nous devons davantage détailler.
Nous avons découvert que les étudiants sont emballés quand ils peuvent utiliser cet outil.
Et même les responsables politiques et les entreprises aimeraient observer
l'évolution du monde. Mais pourquoi cela n'est-il pas mis en place ?
Pourquoi ne pas utiliser les données que nous avons ? Nous possédons des données aux Nations Unies,
dans les agences nationales de statistiques
et dans les universités et les autres organisations non gouvernementales.
Parce que les données sont enfouies dans les bases de données.
Le public est là, Internet est là, mais nous ne les utilisons pas efficacement.
Toutes ces informations que nous voyons changer dans le monde
n'incluent pas les statistiques publiques. Il existe des pages Web
comme celle-ci, mais elles se nourrissent des bases de données,
mais on les rend payantes, on instaure des mots de passe stupides et des statistiques ennuyeuses.
(Rires). (Applaudissements).
Et cela ne marche pas. Que devons-nous faire ? Nous avons les bases de données.
Ce n'est pas de nouvelles bases de données dont nous avons besoin. Nous avons des outils de mise en forme merveilleux,
et il s'en crée de plus en plus. Nous avons donc lancé
une entreprise à but non lucratif que nous avons appelée - en reliant les données à la conception -
nous l'avons appelée "Gapminder", par analogie au métro londonien qui vous avertit
de faire attention au vide. Nous avons donc pensé que "Gapminder" était un nom approprié.
Nous avons donc développé des logiciels qui relient les données comme cela.
Et ce n'était pas si compliqué. Cela nous a pris quelques années, et nous avons produit des animations.
Vous pouvez prendre un ensemble de données et les amener là.
Nous nous sommes procuré des données de l'ONU et de quelques organisations de l'ONU.
Certains pays ont accepté de rendre publiques leurs données,
mais ce dont nous avons réellement besoin c'est, bien sûr, d'une fonction de recherche.
Une fonction de recherche qui nous permettrait de copier les données dans un format accessible
et de les transmettre au monde entier. Et quelles ont été les réactions ?
J'ai fait une recherche anthropologique sur les principales formations statistiques. Tout le monde a dit,
"C'est impossible. On ne peut pas faire ça. Notre information est trop spécifique
et ne peut être partagée comme n'importe quelle autre.
On ne peut pas donner cette information gratuitement aux étudiants et aux entrepreneurs du monde entier."
Mais c'est exactement ce que nous voulons faire, n'est-ce pas ?
Les données publiques sont juste là.
Nous souhaitons qu'elles se développent sur Internet.
L'un des points cruciaux consiste à les rendre accessibles et à faire en sorte que les gens puissent utiliser
les différents outils pour les rendre vivantes.
Et j'ai une bonne nouvelle pour vous.
Le nouveau directeur du service Statistiques de l'ONU ne dit pas que c'est impossible.
Il dit simplement : "On ne peut pas le faire".
(Rires)
C'est plutôt quelqu'un de malin, n'est-ce pas ?
Donc nous allons voir beaucoup de changements se produire dans les années à venir dans le domaine de l'échange des données.
Nous pourrons observer la distribution des richesses de façons complètement nouvelles.
Voici la distribution des richesses en Chine en 1970.
La distribution des richesses aux États-Unis en 1970.
Quasiment aucun chevauchement. Quasiment aucun. Et que s'est-il produit ?
Voici ce qui s'est passé : la Chine a progressé, ce n'est plus si équitable,
et cela se voit ici, dominant les États-Unis.
On dirait un fantôme, n'est-ce pas ?
(Rires).
C'est plutôt effrayant. Mais je pense qu'il est important d'avoir cette information.
Nous devons la voir. Mais au lieu d'approfondir ce sujet,
je voudrais terminer en montrant les utilisateurs d'Internet pour 1 000.
Dans ce logiciel, nous accédons assez facilement à environ 500 variables de tous les pays.
Il faut du temps pour passer à cela,
mais vous pouvez facilement trouver sur les axes n'importe quelle variable de votre choix.
Le but serait que les bases de données soient gratuites,
accessibles et en cliquant une seconde fois, de les obtenir
dans des graphiques, où vous pourrez les comprendre instantanément.
Les statisticiens n'apprécient pas car selon eux, cela
ne reflète pas la réalité. Nous devons avoir une approche statistique et méthodique.
Mais cela génère des hypothèses.
Je termine donc avec le monde. Ici, Internet arrive.
Le nombre d'internautes croît comme cela. Voici le PIB par individu.
C'est une nouvelle technologie qui voit le jour et qui, étonnamment,
se fond avec l'économie des pays. C'est pourquoi l'ordinateur
à 100 dollars est si important. Mais c'est une tendance faible.
C'est comme si le monde s'aplatissait ? Ces pays
se soulèvent plus que l'économie, et il serait intéressant
de suivre ce phénomène au fil des années, comme je souhaiterais que vous puissiez utiliser
les données financées par des fonds publics. Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)